[Musik]
ernste lage weil die infektionszahlen
rasant steigen diskutiert die politik
über einen corona gipfel noch vor ostern
experiment in barcelona kommen 5000
menschen zu einem popkonzert unter
strengen schutzmaßnahme jubel in planica
doppelsieg für karl geiger beim skiflug
weltcup
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster wir kommen bei den
nachrichten am sonntag zusammen mit zehn
fonds für den sport schön gerahmt
gerade noch hat sich die kanzlerin für
die schlecht geplante oster ruhe der
jüngsten bund länder runde entschuldigt
da ist schon ein neues treffen im
gespräch anfang der woche denn die
infektionszahlen steigen und steigen
aus furcht vor im präsidenten mutationen
plädiert heute auch das kanzleramt für
einen strengeren kurs sonst so minister
braun stünden wir wieder mit leeren
händen da wie ernst die korona lage
derzeit ist zeigt der blick auf die
karte
mittlerweile ist die mehrheit der kreise
und städte wieder tiefrot eingefärbt
bundesweit liegt die inzidenz bei knapp
130 und auch der blick nach frankreich
bereitet hierzulande sorgen christoph
distel mit den details die europabrücke
bei kiel drüben in frankreich grassiert
corona fast dreimal stärker als auf
deutscher seite theoretisch gilt daher
seit mitternacht einreise nur mit
frischem test und anschließender
quarantäne
praktisch heißt das vorerst nichts noch
fehlt grünes licht für kontrollen
zurückschicken geht also auch nicht ab
morgen dann vielleicht einzelne
stichproben und verwarnungen wieder
zeigt sich neue maßnahmen gegen das
virus sind im echten leben extrem schwer
umzusetzen und auch dringend nötig
deswegen denkt etwa baden württembergs
ministerpräsident kretschmann
laut über ein vorziehen des nächsten
bund-länder-treffen es nach wir müssen
das auch mit anderen ländern vor
gesprächen mit dem bundeskanzleramt wir
sehen halt die zahlen rasen förmlich
hoch dabei gibt es ja eine beschlossene
maßnahme nennt sich notbremse bei zu
hoher inzidenz leben schließen kontakte
runterfahren
tatsächlich wollen immer mehr länder
etwa berlin bremsen aber doch bitte
maßgeschneidert auf ihre art man muss
gezielt reagieren dort wo die
infektionsketten entstehen und das ist
nun mal wie es geschrieben habe in dem
bereich der direkten kontakte im
privaten bereich und im öffentlichen das
heißt also im beruflichen bereich
und genau an diesen stellen setzen wir
an
daher plant berlin noch mehr home office
und arbeitgeber müssen ihre belegschaft
kostenlose tests anbieten gleichzeitig
bleiben geschäfte offen aber nur für
frisch getestete eigene wege geht auch
mecklenburg vorpommern plant bei
instanzen über 100 nächtliche
ausgangssperren und so wird wohl viel
gebremst werden in den nächsten tagen
aber eben nicht unbedingt genau nach dem
bund länder vorgaben entspannen kann
sich die lage nur wenn irgendwann
genügend menschen geimpft sind doch bis
jetzt läuft der prozess bei uns ja nur
stockend
andere länder sind da weiter zum
beispiel serbien
das hat offenbar so viel impfstoff
eingekauft dass es nicht nur die eigene
bevölkerung immunisieren sondern auch
noch dem ausland impfungen anbieten kann
kostenlos britta hilpert als am
belgrader im zentrum heute morgen die
türen öffnen warten davor impfwillige
aus aller herren länder
denn seit freitag impft serbien alle
auch ausländer die extra anreisen weil
sie in ihren ländern noch warten müssen
wir haben gestern davon gehört und sind
sofort hergekommen weil wir jüngeren in
ungarn noch warten müssen
phänomenal es ist phänomenal sowas gibt
es nirgends in europa jeder beneidet
serbien jeder ist dankbar ich kann es
mir nicht erklären aber das wichtigste
ist doch dass wir geimpft werden
serbiens gründe für die impf hoffnung
sind unklar
denn das land ist längst nicht über den
berg die intensivstationen vielerorts am
limit die inzidenz über 500 serbien
impft mit allem was ich kriegen kann und
hat 13 prozent der bevölkerung
vollständig geimpft ein europäischer
spitzenwert doch auch die im skepsis im
land ist groß
ich lasse mich nicht impfen ich glaub an
solche sachen nicht übrig gebliebene
impfstoffe müssen zügig weg eine ladung
astrazeneca stehe kurz vor dem verfall
heißt es das angebot für ausländer ist
nur begrenzt begonnen
ab morgen oder übermorgen werden wir
wieder wie vorher nur die eigene
wir impfen der impfstoff ist kostenlos
auch für ausländer
serbien ist großzügig und freut sich
schweigend über die dankbarkeit auch von
deutschen die hier nachweislich geimpft
wurden
das gewaltsame vorgehen des militärs in
myanmar wird international scharf
kritisiert der sonderberichterstatter
der uno andrews bezeichnete es als
massenmord die welt müsse eingreifen
seit dem putsch anfang februar gehen
sicherheitskräfte brutal gegen die meist
friedlich demonstrierenden vor
allein gestern sollen mehr als 100
menschen getötet worden sein
trotzdem gingen auch heute wieder viele
auf die straße weniger fleisch essen für
umwelt und gesundheit das fordert das
umweltbundesamt die massentierhaltung
müsse reduziert werden sagte der
präsident des amtes messner der funke
mediengruppe nur so gelangen weniger
stickstoff im boden und wasser
andernfalls drohten sehr teure
klimafolgen die forderung daher halb so
viel fleisch dafür aber qualitativ
besseres jahrzehntelang war es ein teil
der deutschen steinkohle geschichte
jetzt ist es gesprengt worden
das ehemalige kohlekraftwerk in lünen
zunächst muss er 250 meter hohe
schornstein weichen dann wurden
kesselhaus und kühlturm zu fall gebracht
insgesamt drei sprengungen mit 420
kilogramm sprengstoff
auf dem gelände sollen sich künftig neue
unternehmen ansiedeln
gemeinsam feiern singen tanzen die
sehnsucht danach ist besonders bei
jüngeren riesig und scheint doch bei den
steigenden infektionszahlen kaum
erfüllbar zu sein
das spanische barcelona wagte jetzt ein
besonderes experiment eine live band ein
konzert vor 5000 menschen natürlich
unter strenge schutzmaßnahmen thomas
walde
es war ein konzert bei dem es um mehr
ging als die musik der auftritt der band
lavive lesbian war eine demonstration
auch für das publikum
ich habe lust auszugehen und den leuten
zu sagen dass dieses virus uns nicht
kleinkriegen wird
wir versuchen hier zu zeigen dass das
leben weitergeht auch wenn das virus
unter uns ist wichtiger als der sound
check waren in barcelona diese proben
5000 corona tests sechs fielen positiv
aus die ergebnisse gab es aufs handy wir
menschen sind zu hause eingesperrt und
die einzigen lösungen die sie uns
anbieten sind einschränkungen der
mobilität wir glauben das screening eine
der lösungen ist ihren auftritt hatten
auch wissenschaftler in zwei wochen
gleichen sie die daten der
konzertbesucher mit denen des
gesundheitsamtes ab um zu sehen ob
mitsingen mit masken pflicht möglich ist
wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen mit dem
virus zu leben denn es wird uns noch
jahre begleiten die besucher zumindest
hoffen dass es erst mal gut gegangen ist
weshalb das virus ist immer da aber hier
vergisst du es ein bisschen zumindest
für zwei stunden zwei stunden gute laune
ob das ganze turnier tauglich ist zeigt
sich dann in zwei wochen
tja und jetzt zum sonntag sport mit sven
und einem erfolgreichen abschluss für
die deutschen beim skispringen und
fliegen die frauen gehen den
tschaikowsky russland mit einem dritten
platz im team springen aus der saison
karl geiger triumphierte auf der
flugschanze in planica gleich zweimal
mit dem team und im einzel die
überraschung ist ihm anzumerken karl
geiger zeigt im zweiten durchgang seine
bekannte nervenstärke er segelt hinab
auf 232 eineinhalb meter verdrängt den
japaner kobayashi dritter markus
eisenbichler eine punktlandung ich
glaube es war einfach generell von uns
beiden super saison und wir sind sehr
glücklich als bester skiflieger des
winters geehrt steht geiger zudem mit
drei kollegen im nachgeholten
teamwettbewerb ganz oben was für ein tag
auch die skispringerinnen jubeln im
fernen tschaikowsky über platz drei im
team
glückwünsche an den scheidenden trainer
andreas bauer genesungswünsche der
kollegen an den schwer gestürzten
norweger tante der aus dem künstlichen
koma erwacht das ist die beste nachricht
die deutschen u 21 nationalmannschaft
ist auf kurs em-viertelfinale
nach dem 121 gestern abend gegen die
niederlande reicht nun im letzten
gruppenspiel gegen rumänien ein
unentschieden fürs weiterkommen und das
erste rennen der formel 1 saison in
bahrain gewinnt der brite lewis hamilton
der siebenfache weltmeister überquert
die ziellinie knapp vor max verstappen
und valtteri bottas drei runden vor
schluss kommt max verstappen an lewis
hamilton vorbei und geht in führung doch
er verlässt dabei regelwidrig die
strecke kurz darauf muss der
niederländer den weltmeister aus england
wieder vorbeilassen fast appen kann
keinen weiteren angriff starten und so
gewinnt lewis hamilton seinen 96 formel
1 grand prix
valtteri bottas wird dritter für
sebastian vettel ist es ein
enttäuschendes rennen mit einem unfall
als tiefpunkt als er dem alpin von yukon
ins eck fährt am ende platz 15 noch
schlechter läuft es für mich schumacher
ein dreher in der anfangsphase seines
ersten formel 1 grand prix und dem ziel
der letzte platz
und das war der sport am sonntag
dankeschön zum schluss werfen wir noch
einen blick auf das wetter in der
osterwoche und die beginnen morgen im
norden mit wolken und einzelnen schauern
sonst aber gibt es viel sonne und im
südwesten so
meist einen wolkenlosen himmel 12 bis 22
grad
so viel von uns für den moment schön
dass sie dabei waren
claus kleber erwartet sie um drei
viertel 10 zum heute-journal und hier
übernimmt morgen wieder barbara häufig
einen schönen sonntagabend wünschen